well from early on in this crisis we
took the virus seriously but we doubted
that chinese-style lockdowns were a wise
response to the Chinese coronavirus even
if they worked as advertised and as you
just heard there's no overwhelming
evidence that they don't work as
advertised despite what politicians
continue to say mass quarantine under
the best circumstance
are really just a stopgap the only way
to tame a virus like this is with
science a single effective treatment
would make all the difference right away
you wouldn't have to cure every sick
patient but if you could cure a
significant number of sick patients and
lower the death rate this would be a
completely different country hope would
return fear would reside we could begin
to regard this as a manageable illness
as we do so many other illnesses more
than 600,000 Americans for example will
die this year from cancer that's a
tragic number you doubtless know some
but we accept it and we live our lives
bravely in the face of it in part
because cancer horrible as it is isn't
very mysterious anymore there are
treatments for it those treatments sadly
don't always work but they work often
enough that we can manage to live
without panic so it's been obvious from
day one that the main goal here is we
fight this pandemic has got to be
finding effective treatments for the
virus that's obvious and most people
understand that intuitively the
President does he regularly uses his
daily press briefings to tout potential
new medical advances
one of the first off-label drugs that
doctors around the world used to treat
the krona virus was a medicine called
hydroxychloroquine hydroxychloroquine is
a cheap decades old medicine long
recognized as a therapeutic for lupus
and rheumatoid arthritis autoimmune
diseases it was originally an
anti-malaria drug if you've traveled to
the third world it's entirely possible
you have already taken this drug early
evidence suggested that
hydroxychloroquine might be promising
physicians in the hardest-hit countries
Spain and Italy for example reported
that it was their preferred treatment
for the corona virus one day from the
podium the president touted the drug as
a promising lead and that was it for
hydroxychloroquine from that moment on
precisely that moment in the minds the
partisans in our media establishment
hydroxychloroquine was purely a pullet
issue the drug was no longer a medicine
a therapy it was the medical equivalent
of Vladimir Putin it was a cudgel they
can swing in the air mindlessly to hit
their ideological opponents in the hope
of political game they ignored evidence
that hydroxychloroquine might be
effective in some ways they waited
anxiously for evidence that it might not
be and the other day they got it several
recent studies suggest that
hydroxychloroquine is unlikely to help
people who were already severely ill
with the coronavirus for most Americans
this was disappointing news they wanted
it to work but at CNN it was cause for
celebration the network produced a video
for its website tallying up every time
the president had mentioned
hydroxychloroquine a drug called
chloroquine hydroxychloroquine
chloroquine hydroxychloroquine
chloroquine chloroquine
hydroxychloroquine the hydroxy
chloroquine hydroxy chloroquine
hydroxychloroquine that's a lot of good
things are happening with it a lot of
good tests over at the Washington Post
was so often seems to work in tandem was
seen in his shock troops for the
Democratic Party a person called Philip
bump produced a three thousand word long
timeline looking at quote the rise and
fall of Trump's obsession with ad-rock
see chloroquine was yet another exercise
in deep irony bump himself obsessively
chronicled every time the president's
watch is retweeted a message a mention
of the drug bump log the precise number
of times that hydroxychloroquine was
mentioned on this channel and on fox
business paging dr. Freud it's possible
that mr. bump may be exhibiting symptoms
of obsession early this week bump wrote
yet another article on the same topic
and he ended that piece this way with a
suggestion of a sinister conspiracy at
work quote why promote that drug and why
so energetically hmm and he left the
question to hang in the air
philip bump doesn't believe in human
optimism he always assumes a secret
agenda but as usual this was pure
projection with the creeps and big media
accused you of doing every single time
they are fervently doing themselves
they're the ones obsessed with
hydroxychloroquine most people just want
a drug that works they're the ones with
a weird unspoken agenda that's obvious
and yet hidden most people in this
country just want a drug that works and
in fact in some circumstances this drug
may work hydroxychloroquine is still
being used to treat coronavirus patients
dozens of studies of its effectiveness
are now in progress still at this hour
many doctors believe it can help if used
early or in mild cases of the disease
the VA secretary recently said as much
President Trump has touted this but it
is linked to higher rates of death in
the VA coronavirus related can you
elaborate what's going on with this drug
sure that that's an observational study
it's not a clinical study it was done on
a small number of veterans sadly those
of whom were in the last stages of life
and the drug was given to them and I
have to I have to also say that the drug
we know the drug has been working on
middle-aged and younger veterans oh so
correlation is not causation these are
deep waters many people on television
are not prepared they're not wearing
their swimsuits in real life we are
getting mixed results we need to know
more this is how science actually works
it's why we still haven't cured cancer
just by decades of working on it but we
have prolong the lives of cancer
patients significantly that's a victory
these are the kinds of victories you get
in this business real science is
complicated and difficult and almost
always incremental the party of science
no longer understands that because they
left science a long time ago Karen
Whitsett is a Democratic lawmaker in the
state of Michigan she believes she was
suffering from coronavirus and steadily
getting worse
until she received hydroxychloroquine
from her physician then she recovered
once it came on this show to explain
what happened and as she explained it
she gave some credit to a president she
didn't vote for dr. I so while I did
save my life and I do credit you know
the president's of doing so and putting
this out there because it wasn't
excessed
to me if it was for that fat yes I had
very little time to be able to get to
this and be able to make ice because my
breathing did become very labored so you
just saw a woman who at bare minimum
went through a harrowing experience and
escaped with her life
we should celebrate but not everybody is
a Detroit branch of the Democratic Party
says it plans to censure Whitsett and
expel her from the Democratic Party for
daring to meet with the president after
she got well they didn't congratulate
her for surviving they punished her for
violating party orthodoxy